[Musique]
ça pique
mais c'est de la moutarde et ça remonte
dans l'ue mais et dont les yeux vite de
l'eau ça fait du bien
en même temps elle a du bouquet cette
moutarde c'est normal la moutarde est
une plante on a du mal à imaginer que
cette petite fleur soit à l'origine
d'une telle sensation
il faut mail enquête
ces photos ont été prises au printemps
après avoir été fécond b les fleurs
produisent des graines amer une
technique astucieuse pour repousser les
herbivores et les granivores bon il ya
des petits malins comme ce rongeur qui
vit dans le désert du néguev en israël
il se nourrit d'une cousine de la
moutarde mais il prend bien soin de
recracher les graines
c'est pas lui qu'on va apprendre à faire
la grimace c'est à partir de ces graines
que l'on fabrique de la moutarde en
sauce la récolte a lieu durant l'été et
je vais vous montrer à quoi il ressemble
nous sommes dans une moutarderie
familiale l'une des dernières qui
fabrique ce condiment de manière
traditionnelle
elle a été fondée en 1840
c'est une ancienne halle et voici les
tiges de moutarde
elles ont bien changé depuis le
printemps les graines se trouve à
l'intérieur de ce qu'on appelle des
siliques c'est petit causse on dit aussi
parfois des capsules à la journée creuse
une
c'est de la moutarde brune
il existe également de la motarde
blanche de la motor de noir de la
motarde deschamps de la moutarde sauvage
et le colonel moutarde pour ceux qui
connaissent ça ressemble un petit peu
aux graines de colza
c'est normal ces plantes appartiennent à
la même famille les brassicacées
auparavant on disait les crucifères tout
simplement parce que les pétales des
fleurs sont disposés en forme de croix
c'est ta mère je préfère quand ça pique
la recette maintenant d'abord il faut
faire tremper les graines dans un
mélange à base de vinaigre d'eau et de
sel ce qu'on appelle un verges
cette macération permet d'éliminer
l'amertume c'est également à ce stade
que la moutarde devient piquante au
contact du verjus les graines de
moutarde libère des molécules qui vont
se combiner est donnée de l'essence de
moutade de l'iso turcy à nadal il pour
ceux qui ont du goût pour la chimie
là ça pique un peu il a raison on va se
contenter des sens de moutarde
puis les graines sont broyés pour
fabriquer un kilogramme de moutarde
il faut compter 300 g de graines et là
ça pique
mais pourquoi cette sensation de
picotement remonte elle dans le nez et
parfois jusqu'aux yeux
suivez moi d'abord le piquant n'est pas
un goût au sens strict du terme en effet
il existe cinq goûts différents
amer salé acide sucré et umami un goût
très apprécié en asie que nous
occidentaux nous avons un peu de mal à
décrire on le retrouve un petit peu dans
le lait et d'un fromage quand on prend
qu'une carotte le sucre qu'elle contient
se lier avec les récepteurs du sud
présent sur la langue et l'information
est transmise au cerveau qui en déduit
que la carotte et sucrés souvenez vous
il y a quelques mois je vous expliquer
pourquoi on éprouve une sensation de
fraîcheur quand on mange de la menthe
tout simplement parce que le menthol
contenues dans les feuilles de menthe se
lie avec les mêmes récepteurs que ce
sensible au froid
c'est un leurre en quelque sorte avec la
moutarde
il y a un peu de ça quand on mange de la
moutarde ces essences les iso quelque
chose se lier avec des récepteurs
spécifiques à la température voilà
pourquoi on a cette sensation de
picotement et aussi de chaleur et ce
n'est pas tout
ils les essences de moutarde sont très
volatiles elle se diffuse dans toute la
bouche dans les fosses nasales et se lie
avec des récepteurs d'un air particulier
le nerf trijumeau c'est lui qui canalise
toutes les informations recueillies par
le village jusqu'au cerveau je vous ai
fait un petit schéma pour mieux
comprendre il se divise en trois
branches qui innerve la bouche le nez et
les yeux ce qui correspond au préfixe ce
trident trijumeau je vaux parce que
chaque branche se divise en deux côtés
gauche et côté droit c'est grâce à cette
implantation que le chirurgien dentiste
peu anesthésié un côté de la mandibule
et pas l'autre en se diffusant les
essences de moutarde se lie avec des
récepteurs du nerf trijumeau de toutes
ces régions
c'est pourquoi la moutarde cyclone et
fait pleurer alors qu'elle est posée sur
la langue
c'est aussi pour cette raison qu'il faut
bien refermer le pot de moutarde pour
éviter que les essences ne s'échappent
et que la moutarde perd son goût est
maintenant un peu de géographie qui dit
moutarde dit moutarde de dijon dijon et
sa région
c'est la plus connue des moutardes en
france et dans le monde entier cette
renommée ne date pas d'hier
[Musique]
c'est une spécialité de la région la
bourgogne depuis le moyen-age on peut
dire que dès le départ tous les
ingrédients sont réunis pour que la
sauce prenne entre dijon enfin sa région
et la moutarde le sol est propice à la
culture de la plante et comme vous
pouvez le constater on y cultive
énormément de vignes qui donne un
excellent vin dont on utilise une petite
partie pour produire du vinaigre un
ingrédient indispensable pour fabriquer
de la moutarde
à l'origine il y avait même ici un
cépage qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui
le bourg de la dont on tirait un jus le
premier verjus qui a été utilisée pour
faire de la moutarde
toujours est il que des générations de
moutardier vont se succéder dans la
région très vite la moutarde monte sur
la table du roi qui nomme son propre
moutardier le pape en fait autant il
faut croire que la sauce n'est toujours
pas retombée
puisqu'en 2009 ce sont bien des pots de
moutarde que barack obama choisit de
rapporter de son voyage officiel en
france à croire qu'en plus de monter
rooney elle fait tourner les têtes
je reviens pour un petit bonus depuis le
début de cette aventure vous êtes très
nombreux à poser des questions en
commentaires des vidéos
j'ai donc décidé d'y répondre par à tout
quelques-unes celles qui reviennent le
plus souvent et aussi les plus insolites
aujourd'hui au sujet du phénomène
démarre une question de florent et la
méditerranée alors pourquoi n'y at il
pas de marc hé bien si il y à démarrer
dans la mer méditerranée mais elles sont
beaucoup plus faibles d'une quarantaine
de centimètres
la mer méditerranée même si elle est
très profonde est une mer fermée et le
passage qui la relie à l'océan
atlantique détroit de gibraltar est très
étroit il gêne donc le déplacement de
losne de marée et puis il ya une autre
raison le plateau continental
cette zone et qu'il a de la côte
jusqu'au fond marin et qu'il descend
tout doucement cette zone qui est très
large dans l'océan atlantique est très
étroite dans la mer méditerranée par
conséquent la mer baisse est bien l'eau
ne peut pas se retirer sur de longues
distances et pour cette raison que les
marées en mer méditerranée sont
difficilement visibles questions de
carole qui va nous faire voyager ou au
mieux les plus grandes marées au monde
alors en europe
c'est dans la baie du mont saint michel
la mère peut se retirer jusqu'à presse
km le marnage c'est à dire la différence
de hauteur d'eau entre la marée basse et
la marée haute pu atteindre 13 m déjà
énorme mais les plus grandes marées du
monde ont lieu canada dans la baie de
fundy là le marnage atteint 16 mètres de
hauteur ça fait rêver ou cauchemarder
c'est comment voilà pour les marais la
prochaine fois je répondrai à vos
questions sur la moutarde
n'hésitez pas à les laisser en
commentaire de cette vidéo à très
bientôt sur les résoudre sur la chaîne
youtube et à la télévision
haidari